Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In February 2018, the Winter Olympics were held in South Korea. And there was obviously huge interest in the presence at these games of a North Korean team. And perhaps the most dramatic and sensational contribution to the Olympics from the North Koreans was the figure skating competition at which Ryom Tai Ok and Kim Ju Sik performed a stunning routine. And the music to which they performed this routine was A Day in the Life by The Beatles, the last track on perhaps their most famous album, Sgt. Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band. So in 2018, it was what? It was 51 years since Sgt. Pepper had taught the band to play. And yet here were figure skaters
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。2018年2月，冬季奥运会在韩国举行。显然，朝鲜代表团出席本届冬奥会引起了巨大的关注。而朝鲜人对奥运会最引人注目、最轰动的贡献，或许莫过于花样滑冰比赛，廉太玉（Ryom Tai Ok）和金柱希（Kim Ju Sik）在那里表演了一套令人惊叹的动作。他们表演这套动作所用的音乐是披头士乐队的《A Day in the Life》，这是他们最著名的专辑《Sgt. Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band》中的最后一首歌。所以，2018年距离《Sgt. Pepper》教会乐队演奏已经过去了51年。然而，这些花样滑冰选手却来自
from perhaps the most isolationist regime on the face of the planet. A state absolutely committed in its opposition to everything that the West represented. Choosing a track from a pop group that had split up many, many decades before. And I think it's a kind of stunning tribute to the enduring influence of the Beatles and a tribute that I think entirely justifies studying them, not as musicians, but as, I think, seminal figures in modern history.
这个星球上或许最孤立的政权。一个坚决反对西方所代表的一切的国家。他们选择了一首几十年前就已经解散的流行乐队的歌曲。我认为这是对披头士乐队持久影响的一种惊人致敬，我认为这种致敬完全证明了研究他们的必要性——不是作为音乐家，而是作为现代史上具有开创性意义的人物。
And I would go so far as to say that in 100, perhaps 200 years' time, they will still be remembered when almost everyone else from post-war Britain will have been forgotten. And it's a particular thrill for me to be talking about them here because we are doing this live at the Chalk Valley History Festival just outside the village where I grew up. And so a place where I basically discovered the Beatles and listened to them for many, many years. So it's a kind of very personal for me to be here.
我甚至可以说，在100年甚至200年后，当战后英国几乎所有其他人都被遗忘时，人们依然会记得他们。能在这里谈论他们让我感到格外兴奋，因为我们是在粉笔谷历史节（Chalk Valley History Festival）现场录制，地点就在我长大的村庄外。所以，这里是我最初发现披头士并听了他们很多年音乐的地方。对我来说，在这里谈论他们有着非常私人的意义。
With me is Dominic Sandbrook, who has written a series of fantastic books on modern Britain and on the way also that modern Britain has kind of generated a global culture. And so Dominic, the Beatles have been a consistent theme of yours, but I think you might be slightly more sceptical than me about their enduring historical significance. Yeah. Hello, everybody. It's great to be here.
和我在一起的是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），他撰写了一系列关于现代英国以及现代英国如何产生全球文化的精彩书籍。多米尼克，披头士一直是你研究的主题，但我认为你可能比我更怀疑他们持久的历史意义。是的，大家好，很高兴来到这里。
And such a fascinating topic. And yes, Tom, I am more sceptical. I wonder whether the Beatles will have the same cultural capital in, let's say, a century's time or two centuries' time as they still do now. We don't tend to listen to music you know, music from the Victorian era, nor do we listen to George Formby or the sort of pre-Second World War music. We don't tend to listen even to jazz, particularly from the early 20th century. It's quite a niche taste. And I do wonder whether guitar, you know, guitar music, like all kinds of music,
这是一个非常迷人的话题。是的，汤姆，我确实更怀疑。我怀疑披头士在一百年或两百年后是否还能拥有像现在这样相同的文化资本。我们通常不会去听维多利亚时代的音乐，也不会去听乔治·福姆比（George Formby）或二战前的音乐。我们甚至不太听爵士乐，尤其是20世纪早期的爵士乐。那是非常小众的品味。我确实怀疑吉他音乐，你知道，像所有类型的音乐一样，
it dates, it comes from a particular time and place, and whether, you know know in the far future our successors will be as interested in its supreme exponents as we are but where i would agree with you is i do think you know you look back at um the period that i've written about as you say the 60s and 70s and so on you know people who seemed colossal at the time, Harold Wilson won lots of elections. Tony Benn. Tony Benn. Jim Callaghan. He's giant.
它有时代局限性，来自特定的时间和地点。我怀疑在遥远的未来，我们的后代是否还会像我们一样对这些巅峰时期的代表人物感兴趣。但我同意你的一点是，当你回顾我所写的那个时期，也就是60年代和70年代等等，那些当时看起来非常了不起的人，比如哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）赢得了许多选举，托尼·本（Tony Benn），吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan），他们都是巨人。
He's stored the pages of your books. Yes. People that I've spent, I've wasted far too much of my life thinking and writing about. But you're absolutely right. I mean, they have absolutely no traction now at all. I mean, anybody who's interested in Tony Benn under the age of 20, I mean, there's something not right.
他们占据了你书中的篇幅。是的，这些人我花了很多时间，浪费了太多生命去思考和写作。但你是绝对正确的。我的意思是，他们现在完全没有影响力了。如果一个20岁以下的人对托尼·本感兴趣，那肯定有什么地方不对劲。
But I don't say that... I realise I'm in danger of alienating my own readership, which is utter folly. But I do think, yes, culturally they mattered enormously. They defined Britain's image and the eyes of the world in a completely new way, I think, from 1964. From that moment they landed in America, Britain's image did change. And the way that Britain saw itself, I think, from 1964, from that moment they landed in America. Britain's image did change,
但我并不是说……我意识到我有疏远自己读者的危险，那是极其愚蠢的。但我确实认为，是的，他们在文化上非常重要。我认为从1964年开始，他们以一种全新的方式定义了英国在世界眼中的形象。从他们踏上美国土地的那一刻起，英国的形象确实改变了。我认为从1964年他们踏上美国土地的那一刻起，英国看待自身的方式也发生了改变。
and the way that Britain saw itself, I think, changed as well. So should we park the issue of their kind of long-term historical significance? Because you know where I'm going to be going with that. Yeah, of course. Everybody knows where you're going with that. But should we look at the way in which they kind of serve as lightning rods for trends in post-war Britain and the way in which they change it.
英国看待自身的方式，我想也发生了改变。那么，我们是否应该搁置关于他们长期历史意义的问题？因为你知道我要往哪里引。是的，当然。每个人都知道你要往哪里引。但我们是否应该看看他们如何作为战后英国趋势的避雷针，以及他们如何改变了英国。
Yeah. And I guess, so when I began listening to The Beatles, that was in the 70s, and their breakup seemed a very, very long time ago to me, even though this was kind of 1976. But what seemed even further removed was the Second World War. It seemed an unimaginable distance. But, of course, it wasn't at all. And all the Beatles were born during the Second World War.
是的。我想，当我开始听披头士的时候，那是在70年代，尽管当时是1976年左右，但他们的解散对我来说似乎是很久很久以前的事了。但感觉更遥远的是第二次世界大战。那似乎是一个不可想象的距离。但当然，事实并非如此。所有的披头士成员都出生在第二次世界大战期间。
And what I realise now, kind of, you know, with my age and wisdom that I've accrued... Your enormous experience and expertise. Yes, is actually that they exist in the context of the Second World War. Yes, and I think, well, not just so much of the war as of the austerity that followed it and then the relative contentment of sort of mid-50s Britain.
我现在意识到，随着我的年龄增长和智慧积累……你那丰富的经验和专业知识。是的，实际上他们是存在于第二次世界大战的背景下的。是的，我认为，与其说是战争本身，不如说是随之而来的紧缩政策，以及50年代中期英国相对的满足感。
I mean, it's such a wonderfully telling moment that McCartney and Lennon famously meet at the church fete. Well, yes, we'll be coming back to that. You know, the Walton church fete. I don't want to give you a gift to start ranting about your book on the history of Christianity. But, yeah, I think they reflect.
我的意思是，麦卡特尼和列侬在教堂游园会上相遇，这是一个非常具有说明性的时刻。嗯，是的，我们稍后会回到这一点。你知道，沃尔顿教堂游园会。我不想给你一个机会开始抨击你关于基督教历史的书。但是，是的，我认为他们反映了……
You know, they obviously reflect. There's a sort of complacency and a self-satisfaction about 50s Britain that is probably quite at once reassuring but also alienating for them, particularly for John Lennon, I think. They're on the prosperous suburbs of Liverpool but Liverpool itself, even in
你知道，他们显然反映了这一点。50年代的英国有一种自满和自我满足，这可能既让人感到安心，又让他们感到疏离，尤其是对约翰·列侬来说。他们住在利物浦繁荣的郊区，但利物浦本身，即使在
the 50s, even in the early 60s, is still massively bomb-scarred. Yes, it is. You're right. Lennon grew up in a house called Mendips, which tells you his position on the working-class hero. I mean, Lennon grew up in a house called Mendips, which tells you, you know, just about the sort of his position on the kind of class. The working class hero.
50年代，甚至60年代初，仍然满目疮痍。是的，你是对的。列侬长大的房子叫“门迪普斯”（Mendips），这说明了他对“工人阶级英雄”的立场。我的意思是，列侬长大的房子叫“门迪普斯”，这说明了你对那种阶级的立场。工人阶级英雄。
Yeah, the working class hero, exactly. But, I mean, Ringo and George Harrison, they both came from much more modest backgrounds. Ringo especially. I mean, he's born in Bootle, which is really in the heart of the kind of the bomb damage of Liverpool. And actually had a very poor and sort of blighted childhood, blighted by illness.
是的，工人阶级英雄，没错。但是，林戈和乔治·哈里森，他们都来自更卑微的背景。尤其是林戈。我的意思是，他出生在布特尔（Bootle），那真的是利物浦炸弹破坏的核心地带。而且他确实有一个非常贫困和受损的童年，被疾病所困扰。
I mean, he's in and out of a hospital, Ringo. It's astonishing that Ringo, who's the one who really should be, you know, he should have a sense of himself as a victim and feel that he's being hard done by. He's incredibly jolly and... Well, because he... Yeah. He got the lottery ticket of all lottery tickets, didn't he?
我的意思是，林戈总是进出医院。令人惊讶的是，林戈本应该是那个应该认为自己是受害者并感到自己受到不公正待遇的人。但他却非常快乐，而且……嗯，因为他……是的。他中了所有彩票中的那张大奖，不是吗？
He did. He did. But I guess also what I mean about the Second World War is that when the Beatles go to Hamburg, they're going to a city that even more than Liverpool bears terrible scars from the war. And I think the Beatles do recognise that because there's a famous account, the first time that they're in their minivan, driving from Liverpool
他确实中了。但我猜我所说的关于第二次世界大战的意思是，当披头士去汉堡时，他们去的是一个比利物浦承受了更多战争创伤的城市。我认为披头士确实意识到了这一点，因为有一个著名的说法，他们第一次开着小货车从利物浦
to Hamburg, and it's a trip that then takes an incredibly long time. They get to Arnhem and most of the Beatles get out to go and look at the war graves and John Lennon refuses. He doesn't want to do it. I think he goes off and nicks a harmonica, doesn't he? Oh my God, there we go.
前往汉堡，那是一段耗时极长的旅程。他们到达阿纳姆（Arnhem）时，大多数披头士成员下车去参观战争公墓，但约翰·列侬拒绝了。他不想去。我想他走开了，还偷了一把口琴，对吧？天哪，就是这样。
Give peace a chance. So even then Lenin is kind of, has a I mean he's anxious and twitchy about the legacy of the war. And then they get to Hamburg and the clubs that they're working in, the Red
给和平一个机会。所以即使在那时，列侬也对战争的遗产感到焦虑和不安。然后他们到了汉堡，他们工作的俱乐部，在红灯区，
Light District, it's staffed by ex-Nazis, and they've all got kind of missing limbs and eyes and things, because this is the only place that they can get jobs. Yeah. I mean, I think there's another dimension to it too, which is if you think, when they get their MBEs in 1965, one of the big complaints is that the MBEs should be for people who,
那里雇佣的都是前纳粹分子，他们都有残肢、眼睛受伤等情况，因为这是他们唯一能找到工作的地方。是的。我的意思是，我认为这还有另一个维度，如果你想想，当他们在1965年获得大英帝国勋章（MBE）时，最大的抱怨之一是MBE应该颁发给那些在战争中参与过战斗的人。
the kind of people who saw action in the war. And you get lots of stories of servicemen sending back their medals in protest to Buckingham Palace or to Downing Street and complain to the Wilson government. And I think what the Beatles also are, Tom, is they're absolutely emblematic of that generation that were too young, obviously, to have fought in the war,
你会看到很多军人为了抗议而把勋章寄回白金汉宫或唐宁街，并向威尔逊政府投诉。我认为披头士也是那一整代人的象征，他们显然太年轻了，没有参加过战争，
too young to have been massively affected by it and are sick of hearing about it. So you definitely get that. That's a very pronounced thing in 60s British youth culture. You have this generation who have basically grown up in the shadow of the war, but they didn't know it firsthand. And they're tired of being lectured about it.
太年轻了，没有受到战争的巨大影响，而且厌倦了听到关于战争的事情。所以你肯定会感觉到这一点。这在60年代的英国青年文化中是一个非常显著的特征。这一代人基本上是在战争的阴影下长大的，但他们并没有亲身经历过。他们厌倦了被说教。
They see the heroism and the sacrifice and all those stories, they see them as basically comical and oppressive. Yeah, and John Lennon's middle name is Winston, which he then famously goes on to change. I guess the other way in which the Beatles are, they have a kind of brush with the lingering militarism of Britain after the war is that they miss out on national service. Yes.
他们把英雄主义、牺牲和所有那些故事基本上看作是滑稽和压迫性的。是的，约翰·列侬的中间名是温斯顿，后来他著名地改掉了。我想披头士与战后英国残留的军国主义产生碰撞的另一种方式是，他们错过了国民服役（National Service）。是的。
Very, very narrowly. I mean, had they gone on national service, I think their story would have obviously been utterly different. And it's impossible to imagine them, you know, having the freedom that they had to experiment, to go to Hamburg, to do all that sort of stuff. So, I mean, in terms of the youth culture generally of the 60s, the fact that national service ends is pretty fundamental, isn't it?
非常非常惊险。我的意思是，如果他们去服了国民兵役，我想他们的故事显然会完全不同。而且无法想象他们能拥有那种自由去实验、去汉堡、去做所有那些事情。所以，就60年代的青年文化而言，国民服役的结束是相当根本的，不是吗？
Yeah, I suppose so, although you could also argue that National Service creates a kind of shared humour, the sort of humour that you get with the goons and that sort of stuff that then gets picked up and made mainstream in the 60s. But you're right, I think there's a definite... The Beatles and their generation reflect a a relaxation a sense of loosening a sense of opportunities these are people as you say haven't had national service but they're also grown up in a world of full employment
是的，我想是这样，尽管你也可以争辩说国民服役创造了一种共同的幽默感，那种你在“笨蛋”（The Goons）节目中看到的幽默，后来在60年代变得主流。但你是对的，我认为有一种明确的……披头士和他们那一代人反映了一种放松、一种松动、一种机会感。正如你所说，这些人没有服过国民兵役，但他们也成长在一个充分就业的世界里，
where more people are in education but if you go out of education you walk into a job you can change jobs at the drop of a hat there's a a lot of money around, there's a lot of opportunity, there's a lot of optimism. And so, you know, great artists, they have greatness in themselves, but also they always reflect the sort of social and commercial conditions, if you like. The marketplace is there for the Beatles. There are an awful lot of young people with a lot of money, with more money than any similar generation before them. And there are a lot of promoters and so on, record companies that are very keen to separate them from that money. And that is where bands
那里有更多的人接受教育，如果你离开学校，你就能找到工作，你可以随时换工作，周围有很多钱，有很多机会，有很多乐观情绪。所以，伟大的艺术家，他们自身有伟大之处，但他们也总是反映了社会和商业条件。披头士的市场就在那里。有大量的年轻人拥有大量的钱，比之前任何类似的一代人都有钱。而且有很多推广人等等，唱片公司非常渴望把这些钱从他们手中赚走。这就是像披头士这样的乐队
like the Beatles come in. And Beatlemania, which, so the Beatles get together, they hone their craft in Hamburg, in Liverpool, and then they go, first they go viral nationally, and then they go viral internationally. And Beatlemania, the way in which girls particularly just kind of scream their heads off, it's kind of basically about fun, isn't it? And I guess it's one of the reasons why the memory of that lingers on decades after it happened is that it was filmed, that people could listen to the music and the conjunction of it served as a kind of emblematic display of coming out of austerity.
出现的原因。披头士狂热（Beatlemania），披头士聚在一起，在汉堡、利物浦磨练技艺，然后他们先是在全国走红，接着在国际上走红。披头士狂热，尤其是女孩们尖叫的方式，基本上是关于乐趣的，不是吗？我想这也是为什么在它发生几十年后，人们对它的记忆依然存在的原因之一，因为它被拍摄了下来，人们可以听音乐，而这种结合成为了一种走出紧缩政策的象征性展示。
Yeah, I think you're right, Tom. I mean, I could spend hours sort of ranting on about this because, as you say, I've written about it. I think Beatlemania... So Beatlemania is really 1963 and 1964. And it comes at a moment when the economy was growing enormously. So Harold Macmillan's chancellor, Reginald Maudling,
是的，我想你是对的，汤姆。我的意思是，我可以花几个小时来谈论这个，因为正如你所说，我写过它。我认为披头士狂热……所以披头士狂热实际上是在1963年和1964年。它出现在经济高速增长的时刻。所以哈罗德·麦克米伦（Harold Macmillan）的财政大臣雷金纳德·莫德林（Reginald Maudling），
had unleashed what he called his dash for growth. So there's just tons of money swilling around. The economy is actually overheating in 1963. Rock and roll had come in in the late 50s, but rock and roll had actually gone into a bit of a decline.
发起了他所谓的“增长冲刺”。所以周围有大量的钱在流动。1963年经济实际上已经过热了。摇滚乐在50年代末兴起，但实际上已经开始衰落了。
So a lot of record companies thought, well, that was the big fad, and now what's next? And actually, if you looked at the charts in 1962, before the Beatles come through, there's all kinds of actually, if you looked at the charts in 1962, before the Beatles come through,
所以很多唱片公司认为，好吧，那是个大潮流，现在接下来是什么？实际上，如果你看看1962年的排行榜，在披头士出现之前，
there's all kinds of weird stuff. There's yodelling. There's sort of Hawaiian music. There's Ackerbilk. Well, you know, in 1987, Mrs. Thatcher was interviewed by Smash Hits and asked for her favourite Beatles track, and she said, Telstar.
有各种各样奇怪的东西。有约德尔唱法。有夏威夷音乐。有阿克·比尔克（Acker Bilk）。嗯，你知道，1987年，撒切尔夫人接受《Smash Hits》杂志采访时被问及她最喜欢的披头士歌曲，她说，《Telstar》。
Yes. Her finger on the nub of youth as ever. Yeah, no, I mean, so Beatlemania, the Beatles come through at the turn of 1963 and they come through at the moment when there's lots
是的。她一如既往地抓住了年轻人的脉搏。是的，不，我的意思是，披头士狂热，披头士在1963年之交出现，他们出现在有很多
of young people, exactly that. There's people at 17, 18, particularly as you say, girls, who I mean, the classic thing is a girl, teenage girls who've got money, they've either left school and they're maybe working in shops or something, or they are still
年轻人的时刻，正是那样。有17、18岁的人，正如你所说，特别是女孩，我的意思是，典型的情况是女孩，十几岁的女孩有钱，她们要么离开了学校，可能在商店工作，要么还在
at school, but they maybe work part-time at a hairdresser's, that's what Twiggy did, Leslie Hornby. So there's thousands upon thousands of people like this. You read Rob Sheffield's book on the Beatles? I haven't. A couple of years ago and it's about
上学，但可能在理发店做兼职，这就是崔姬（Twiggy）做的事，莱斯利·霍恩比（Leslie Hornby）。所以有成千上万这样的人。你读过罗伯·谢菲尔德（Rob Sheffield）关于披头士的书吗？我没读过。几年前读的，它不是关于
it's not so much about the Beatles but about the fans experience of the Beatles. He makes a wonderful point that the Beatles wrote their songs for girls. Yes. I mean girls are the key. They loved girls. Girls are the absolutely key driver of a lot of the sort of 60s. A lot of the kind of 60s fashion, 60s music. Girls are the most important driver of a lot of the 60s, of a lot of the 60s fashion, 60s music.
披头士本身，而是关于粉丝对披头士的体验。他提出了一个精彩的观点，即披头士是为女孩写歌的。是的。我的意思是女孩是关键。他们爱女孩。女孩是60年代许多潮流的绝对关键驱动力。60年代的许多时尚、60年代的音乐。女孩是60年代许多潮流、60年代许多时尚、60年代音乐的最重要驱动力。
Girls are the most important part of the market. So Brian Epstein, when he's remodelling the Beatles, when he takes them from Hamburg... Gives them their suits. Gives them their suits, gets them to look clean and all this. This is all designed for teenage girls and their parents to make the Beatles acceptable for that audience. So you have that.
女孩是市场中最重要的部分。所以布莱恩·爱泼斯坦（Brian Epstein），当他重塑披头士时，当他把他们从汉堡带回来……给他们穿上西装。给他们穿上西装，让他们看起来干净利落等等。这一切都是为十几岁的女孩和她们的父母设计的，为了让披头士被那个受众所接受。所以你有这个。
And then I think another element of Beatlemania is there is a thirst for sensation in 1963. It's the dog days of the Macmillan government. You've got the Profumo scandal going on. There's a sense that there's a sort of... The order of things that has existed since the war is tired. People talk of this old establishment
然后我认为披头士狂热的另一个因素是1963年对轰动效应的渴望。那是麦克米伦政府的末日。普罗富莫丑闻（Profumo scandal）正在发生。有一种感觉，有一种……自战争以来存在的秩序已经疲惫不堪。人们谈论这个老建制派，
that's old Etonian, clapped out. So these northern, I mean it's crucial that they're northern, working class boys. They represent something new, a new Britain. And you've got the end of the Lady Chatterley band. Philip Larkin famously put it about discovering. Yeah, you've got the end of the
那是伊顿公学的老派，已经过时了。所以这些北方的，我的意思是他们是北方人这一点至关重要，工人阶级的男孩。他们代表了新的东西，一个新的英国。而且你有《查泰莱夫人的情人》禁令的结束。菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin）著名地写道关于发现。是的，你有
exactly, you've had the in recent years you've had the Chatter about discovering yeah you've got the end of the exactly you've had the in recent years you've had the Chatterley trial you've got the BBC and ITV competing
没错，你最近几年经历了查泰莱审判，你有BBC和ITV在
very aggressively for younger viewers so launching programmes like Ready Steady Go which some of our older listeners may remember
为年轻观众进行非常激烈的竞争，所以推出了像《Ready Steady Go》这样的节目，我们的一些老听众可能还记得，
these sort of pop music programmes which would have been unthinkable ten years before. So in other words, the arena, the stage is ready. All that is missing are the actors. And the interesting question is, had the Beatles not met,
这些流行音乐节目在十年前是不可想象的。换句话说，舞台已经准备好了。唯一缺少的是演员。有趣的问题是，如果披头士没有相遇，
had Leonard McCartney not met in 1957, the Walton Church phase... Would something else have... Would something else, would there be another band that would have enjoyed similar start-up? My answer to that would be yes. But it might not have been British, I guess. No, I think it would
如果列侬和麦卡特尼没有在1957年相遇，在沃尔顿教堂游园会……会有别的东西吗？会有另一个乐队享受类似的起步吗？我的回答是肯定的。但我想它可能不是英国的。不，我认为它
have been British. I think there would have been a British band, and I also think there would have been a British invasion, because the market in America in particular was sated. They were just doing the same repetitive things. Also, crucially, it took a British band,
会是英国的。我认为会有一个英国乐队，我也认为会有一场“英国入侵”，因为美国的市场特别饱和。他们只是在做同样重复的事情。此外，至关重要的是，需要一个英国乐队，
a white British band, to re-export black American music. So we've talked about how the Beatles actually are, in terms of the transformation in Britain in the early 60s, are very significant as a cultural phenomenon in a British context. But of course, famously, they also become incredibly significant in America.
一个白人英国乐队，来重新出口美国黑人音乐。所以我们已经谈到了披头士在60年代初英国的转型方面，作为英国背景下的文化现象是非常重要的。但当然，众所周知，他们在美国也变得极其重要。
Yes. And it's a kind of explosive impact that they have when they go in 64. And it's a few months after Kennedy's been assassinated. And there is a feeling that, just as the Beatles licensed people in Britain to have fun, so in the wake of the Kennedy assassination, the Beatles appearance on The Ed Sullivan Show says
是的。他们在64年去美国时产生了一种爆炸性的影响。那是在肯尼迪遇刺几个月后。有一种感觉，就像披头士授权英国人去享受乐趣一样，在肯尼迪遇刺之后，披头士在《埃德·沙利文秀》（The Ed Sullivan Show）上的出现说，
yeah, it's fine. Go and have a scream. Yeah, I think it makes a... Obviously, this is why they had to be British. They have to speak English, but they have to seem exotic. And I think what they do is they're a different kind of Englishness that American audiences are not familiar with.
是的，没关系。去尖叫吧。是的，我认为这产生了一个……显然这就是为什么他们必须是英国人。他们必须说英语，但他们必须看起来很异国情调。我认为他们所做的是一种美国观众不熟悉的英式风格。
So there's a lot of talk in America about their accents and people can't place them. I think you're right that there's a sort of appetite for them because America has just had this enormously traumatic episode on the 22nd of November where Kennedy has been shot. So you're literally talking about two months later. I mean, the Beatles' impact in America, it would be fun to find some sort of clever way
所以在美国有很多关于他们口音的讨论，人们无法定位他们。我认为你是对的，有一种对他们的胃口，因为美国刚刚在11月22日经历了肯尼迪被枪杀这一极其创伤性的事件。所以你实际上是在谈论两个月后。我的意思是，披头士在美国的影响，如果能找到某种聪明的方法
of undervaluing it or puncturing it, but you can't, because it's simply extraordinary. At one point, they hold the top five spots on the Billboard Hot 100, which is this coveted chart, which looms so large in American cultural life in the early 60s. The Beatles are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
来低估或戳破它会很有趣，但你做不到，因为它简直太非凡了。有一次，他们占据了公告牌百强单曲榜（Billboard Hot 100）的前五名，这是这个令人垂涎的榜单，在60年代初的美国文化生活中占据了如此重要的地位。披头士是1、2、3、4、5。
I think what's extraordinary about that is basically British music was nothing before that. Ackerbilk bizarrely had had... Cliff had made appearances in America, but universal indifference. Nobody had had had... Cliff. But Cliff had made appearances in America, but universal indifference.
我认为非凡之处在于，基本上在那之前英国音乐什么都不是。阿克·比尔克奇怪地有过……克里夫（Cliff）曾在美国露面，但普遍冷漠。没有人……克里夫。但克里夫曾在美国露面，但普遍冷漠。
I mean, nobody had been interested in Cliff. And I think part of it was that Britain itself, the British brand, as it were, was so closely associated, particularly with empire. It's seen as old, it is stuffy. Tweedy. Hierarchy. Exactly, it's Tweedy. It's Harold McMillan.
我的意思是，没有人对克里夫感兴趣。我认为部分原因是英国本身，所谓的英国品牌，与帝国联系得太紧密了。它被视为古老、陈腐。粗花呢。等级制度。没错，就是粗花呢。是哈罗德·麦克米伦。
And then these guys arrive from Britain and they're a completely new kind of Britishness. And I think, as well, exactly, it's Tweed, it's Harold McMillan. And then these guys arrive from Britain and they're a completely new kind of Britishness. And I think as well, Tom, I mean, I noticed the talk was billed. It was. Was that your doing? Well, we're replacing somebody who is due to talk about the British Empire.
然后这些家伙从英国到达，他们是一种全新的英式风格。而且我认为，同样，没错，是粗花呢，是哈罗德·麦克米伦。然后这些家伙从英国到达，他们是一种全新的英式风格。而且我认为，汤姆，我注意到这次演讲的标题。确实是。那是你的主意吗？嗯，我们正在取代一个原本要谈论大英帝国的人。
So to persuade people to come here, I had to put in something about the British Empire for the title. So obviously, I'm sorry, we're not talking really about the British Empire but they're here now right and they're not leaving well I mean there's people leaving over there
所以为了说服人们来这里，我必须在标题中加入一些关于大英帝国的内容。所以显然，很抱歉，我们并没有真正谈论大英帝国，但他们现在就在这里，对吧？而且他们不会离开。嗯，我的意思是，那边有人离开，
people listening to this on the podcast it will make no sense at all no no no that's fine I mean it never makes any sense on the podcast anyway but on the British Empire angle I mean they become they become members of the British Empire well yeah members of the order of the British Empire yes they do and they wear British Imperial outfits they, yeah, members of the Order of the British Empire. Yes, they do.
在播客上听这个的人会觉得完全没意义。不，不，没关系，反正播客上从来都没什么意义。但关于大英帝国的角度，我的意思是他们成为了大英帝国的成员。嗯，是的，大英帝国勋章的成员，是的，他们是，而且他们穿着大英帝国的服装。他们，是的，大英帝国勋章的成员。是的，他们是。
And they wear British Imperial outfits. They do, yes. So Sgt Pepper is quite subversive, isn't it? In a way that I don't think I properly appreciated when I first listened to it. No, I think that's right. But they can only do that because the British Empire is already gone. I think that's the interesting thing, and that's when I saw the name of
而且他们穿着大英帝国的服装。他们确实是，是的。所以《Sgt Pepper》相当具有颠覆性，不是吗？以一种我第一次听时没有充分意识到的方式。不，我认为那是对的。但他们只能这样做，因为大英帝国已经不存在了。我认为这是有趣的地方，当我看到
the event. I was like, what? Because I think that's the interesting thing. And that's when I saw the name of the event. I was like, what? Because I think one of the key things to the Beatles' success is they are able to export Britishness, as it were, abroad because Britain is no longer feared, because Britain is no longer the bully. I mean, there are obviously places that have kind of memories of Britain as the bully.
活动的名称时。我就想，什么？因为我认为这是有趣的地方。当我看到活动的名称时。我就想，什么？因为我认为披头士成功的关键之一是他们能够向国外出口所谓的英式风格，因为英国不再被恐惧，因为英国不再是恶霸。我的意思是，显然有些地方对英国作为恶霸有记忆。
But because Britain is no longer, you know, Lord Palmerston, gunboat diplomacy, throwing its weight around, and Britain is already, by the early 1960s, beginning to look a bit of a joke, that sort of carnivalesque Britishness, oh, we'll wear Union Jack pants or something. Yeah, swinging 60s. Swinging 60s sort of stuff.
但因为英国不再是，你知道，帕默斯顿勋爵（Lord Palmerston），炮舰外交，到处施加压力，而且到60年代初，英国已经开始看起来有点像个笑话了，那种狂欢节式的英式风格，哦，我们会穿米字旗裤子之类的。是的，摇摆的60年代。摇摆的60年代那种东西。
Exactly, I think you can do that. So in other words, the barriers to British cultural exports are lower because Britain is not the sort of domineering military power anymore. But also, I mean, just picking up on what you said about it takes
没错，我认为你可以那样做。换句话说，英国文化出口的障碍降低了，因为英国不再是那种专横的军事强国了。但同时，我的意思是，接着你刚才说的关于需要
a white British band to re-export black music to white America. I mean, they, in quite a subtle way, they do intrude on the very toxic racial politics of America in the 60s. Because, for instance, they don't play in segregated stadium. Yeah.
一个白人英国乐队来向白人美国重新出口黑人音乐。我的意思是，他们以一种相当微妙的方式，确实干预了60年代美国非常有害的种族政治。因为，例如，他们不在种族隔离的体育场演出。是的。
And they are very, very open about the huge influence that black American music had on them. They don't play in South Africa. And so there is also that sense of a kind of internationalism that will become increasingly a part of their brand moving through the 60s. Yeah, and I think actually that's there from, as you say, as soon as they make that first flight to America
而且他们非常非常公开地谈论美国黑人音乐对他们的巨大影响。他们不去南非演出。所以也有那种国际主义的感觉，这种感觉在60年代随着他们的发展，越来越成为他们品牌的一部分。是的，而且我认为实际上从你所说的，他们一做出那次飞往美国的第一次飞行，
at the beginning of 1964, I think even at that moment, they're not ceasing to be a British phenomenon, but the Britishness is then in tension with their kind of international phenomenon, if you like. On the racial stuff, I mean, that's even more pronounced, I think, with the Rolling Stones, because the Rolling Stones' debt to Mississippi,
在1964年初，我认为即使在那一刻，他们也没有停止成为一种英国现象，但英式风格随后与他们那种国际现象产生了张力。关于种族问题，我的意思是，我认为这在滚石乐队（Rolling Stones）身上表现得更为明显，因为滚石乐队对密西西比、
Delta, Blues, is far more... But Eric. But I mean, Eric Clapton, likewise, has a massive debt to them, and that doesn't stop him having a massive racist rant at one point. Yeah, that's true. So it's not inevitable. No, so the two don't necessarily go hand in hand, but you're right.
三角洲、蓝调的债务要多得多……但埃里克（Eric）。但我的意思是，埃里克·克莱普顿（Eric Clapton）同样对他们有巨大的债务，但这并没有阻止他在某个时候发表大规模的种族主义咆哮。是的，那是真的。所以这不是必然的。不，所以两者不一定齐头并进，但你是对的。
I think the Beatles, I mean, the Beatles are by far the most popular, and also the most popular with sort of middle American girls. Yeah. So I think that's very important um but so they they do come to be seen by conservative elements in america as a threat they do well obviously so can we come on to um yeah bring it up bring it up come on so john lennon famously says that the beatles are bigger bigger than Jesus and he says that to Maureen Cleave in an interview in the Evening Standard in London
我认为披头士，我的意思是，披头士是迄今为止最受欢迎的，也是在美国中产阶级女孩中最受欢迎的。是的。所以我认为这非常重要，嗯，但他们确实被美国保守派视为一种威胁。他们确实。好吧，显然。所以我们可以谈谈……是的，提出来，提出来，来吧。所以约翰·列侬著名地说披头士比耶稣更受欢迎，他在伦敦《标准晚报》（Evening Standard）的一次采访中对莫琳·克里夫（Maureen Cleave）说了这句话，
and it's run in the Evening Standard and nobody in Britain pays any attention to it at all and then it gets reprinted in America as they're going for in 66 they're going for what will turn out to be their last tour and as it were all hell breaks out and you start to get people holding public burnings yes they're organized albums but beatles wigs organized by radio stations well so um are the beatles minstrels of the antichrist asked the christian crusade in october 1966 and david a noble a tulsa pastor, said of the Beatles that the communists, through their scientists, educators and entertainers, have contrived a scientific technique
它在《标准晚报》上刊登，英国没有人注意它，然后它在美国被转载，当时是66年，他们正要去进行他们最后一次巡演，结果天翻地覆，你开始看到人们举行公开焚烧活动。是的，他们组织了专辑，披头士假发，由广播电台组织。嗯，所以……披头士是反基督的吟游诗人吗？1966年10月基督教十字军（Christian Crusade）问道，塔尔萨（Tulsa）的牧师大卫·A·诺布尔（David A. Noble）谈到披头士时说，共产党人通过他们的科学家、教育家和艺人，设计了一种科学技术，
directed at rendering a generation of American youth useless through nerve jamming, mental deterioration and retardation. Yeah. Strong. Strong words. I think he has a point. Well, you know who would agree with you? Elvis. So Elvis also believed this. I have a slightly different perspective from from elvis very similar characters yeah so elvis by this point is kind of hanging out with nixon isn't he and getting well of course he's going to get a badge well elvis you're right he goes to visit richard
旨在通过神经干扰、精神退化和迟钝，使一代美国青年变得无用。是的。强硬。强硬的措辞。我认为他有道理。嗯，你知道谁会同意你的观点吗？猫王（Elvis）。所以猫王也相信这一点。我有一个与猫王略有不同的视角，非常相似的人物。是的，所以猫王到这个时候正和尼克松混在一起，不是吗？而且……当然他会得到一个徽章。嗯，猫王，你是对的，他去白宫拜访了理查德·尼克松，嗯，是的，他说他想志愿成为一名联邦特工。尼克松给了他一个徽章。他说披头士正在输入共产主义者。而且他们非常热衷于毒品，猫王声称他不是。他从来没有过。然后他走开，在白宫吞了一些药丸。
nixon at the white house and um yes he says he wants to volunteer to be a federal agent. Nixon gives him a badge. And he says the Beatles are importing communists. And they're very keen on drugs, which Elvis claims he's not. He never had. And he then goes off and gobbles some pills in the White House.
是的，但无论如何，来吧。给我们你的理论。给我们你的……嗯，我认为美国宗教保守派担心披头士的影响是正确的，因为我确实认为，这就是我证明他们具有某种世界
Yeah, but anyway, come on. Give us your theory. Give us your... Well, I think that American religious conservatives are right to be anxious about the influence of the Beatles because I do think, and this is my justification for saying that they have a kind of world
历史意义的理由，我认为60年代是西方文化转型和剧变的时期，我认为未来几代人会将其与1520年代相提并论。所以我认为我们，在目前，
historical significance, I think that the 60s are a period of cultural transformation and convulsion in the West that I think future generations will rank alongside the 1520s. So I think that we, at the moment,
这就是人们所说的文化战争的很大一部分，那种我们被剧烈震荡的文化错位和冲突感。我认为这是一个持续过程的一部分，也许在，我不知道，30、40年后，它会得到一个像“宗教改革”一样的名字，使它能够被完整地研究。但显然，如果你在1570年代回顾，
and this is a kind of huge part of what people call the culture wars, the sense of cultural dislocation and conflict that we're massively convulsed by. I think this is part of a continuous process that perhaps in, I don't know, 30, 40 years will get a name like the Reformation that will enable it to be studied in its entirety. But obviously, if you're in the 1570s, looking back,
正在发生的事情是非常混乱的。你并没有以同样的方式理解正在发生的事情。我认为我们正在经历非常相似的事情，我认为60年代基本上是这种剧变的中心。我认为披头士是这种剧变的伟大吟游诗人。所以我会做的类比
what's happening is very confused. You don't have a sense of what's going on in quite the same way. I think we're living through something very similar, and I think that the 60s are basically the kind of the epicentre of this convulsion. And I think that the Beatles are the kind of the great minst this convulsion. And I think that the Beatles are the kind of the great minstrels of it. And so the parallel that I would make
与前几代人相比，不会是音乐或爵士乐之类的。它会是赞美诗作者。所以它会是卫理公会的韦斯利兄弟（Wesleys）。但最重要的是，它会是1520年代的赞美诗作者，路德（Luther）等等。
with people of previous generations wouldn't be with musical or jazz or anything like that. It would be with the hymnists. So it would be with the Wesleys for Methodism. But above all it would be with the hymn writers in the 1520s, Luther and so on.
因为新教的影响当然是通过路德撰写的小册子传达的。我的意思是，这很清楚。但它也通过歌曲传达给那些不识字的人。我认为披头士和60年代所有的音乐，
Because the impact of Protestantism is certainly conveyed through the pamphlets that Luther is writing. I mean, that's clear. But it is also conveyed to people who can't read through song. And I think that the Beatles and all the music of the 60s,
影响是巨大的，因为它使人们能够以一种易于理解和娱乐的方式，重新评估相当基本的道德、宗教、文化原则，
the impact is massive because it makes accessible and entertaining re-evaluations of fairly fundamental moral, religious, cultural principles
这些原则我们现在认为是理所当然的。你不是在谈论《Please Please Me》，对吧？我不是在谈论……你是在谈论《All You Need Is Love》。我谈论的是爱很重要的观点。所以我确实认为，你知道，《Please Please Me》或者，你知道，所有披头士狂热的歌曲，爱是重要的那种方式，
that now we take for granted. You're not talking about please, please me here, are you? I'm not talking... You're talking about all you need is love. I'm talking about the idea that love matters. And so I do think that, you know, please, please me or, you know, all the Beatlemania songs, the way in which love is what matters,
享受乐趣是重要的，我认为在当时的环境下是具有颠覆性的。但显然它扩展开了，当我们进入1966年、1967年，“爱之夏”（Summer of Love），《Sgt Pepper》等等，《All You Need Is Love》，那是一个非常意识形态化的
having fun is what matters, I think is subversive in the context. But obviously it expands out, and as we come into 1966, 1967, The Summer of Love, Sergeant Pepper and so on, All You Need Is Love, that is a very ideological
运动，我认为。汤姆，我完全不同意这一点。当然你会不同意，因为我知道你现在要提到《音乐之声》（The Sound of Music）。不，我不会提到《音乐之声》。你要提到《音乐之声》卖出的专辑比……嗯，确实卖出了，我很高兴你提到了这一点。这表明你记得你的阅读，这非常令人高兴。我记得，我记得。
movement, I think. Tom, I would disagree with that completely. Of course you would, because I know you're now going to mention The Sound of Music. No, I'm not going to mention The Sound of Music. You're going to mention how The Sound of Music sold more albums than... Well, it did, and I'm glad you brought that up. It shows that you remember your reading, which is very pleasing. I do, I do.
但是，我的意思是，如果你看看人们在爱德华时代的音乐剧中听什么，士兵们进入战壕时唱的歌，我的意思是，它们都是关于爱和他们的爱人，手牵手，她正在，你知道，为我点燃蜡烛。爱在流行歌曲中一直扮演着角色。
But, I mean, if you look at what people were listening to in Edwardian musical, the songs that soldiers sang when they went into the trenches, I mean, they're all about love and their sweethearts and holding hands and she's holding, you know, burning a candle for me. And love has always played a part in popular song.
绝对。但发生的事情是，那种认为爱应该适当地激励社会的观念，比父母、牧师、学校老师或任何传统等级制度的代表的严格要求更重要。这是影响，我想是因为它被技术放大了，
Absolutely. But what happens is that that sense of love as something that should properly animate society, that is more important than the strictures of parents or priests or school teachers or any of the kind of representatives of traditional hierarchy. It's the impact, I suppose because it's amplified by technology,
被电视、广播等等放大了。它产生了一股浪潮，开始削弱传统的权威结构。然后在60年代下半叶，披头士在将其渲染成一个公开的意识形态纲领方面发挥了关键作用。好吧，汤姆，这提出了一个非常有趣的问题，
by TV, by radio and so on. It generates a groundswell that starts to undermine traditional structures of authority. And then in the second half of the 60s, the Beatles play a key role in rendering this an overtly ideological programme. Okay, Tom, so that raises a really interesting question,
那就是披头士在多大程度上是变革的推动者，你似乎暗示他们是，或者他们在多大程度上反映了……我认为两者都有。……那些本就已经会实现的趋势？我认为两者都有。而且我认为那
which is how much of the Beatles, the agents of change, which you seem to suggest that they are, or how much are they reflecting... I think it's both. ...trends that would already have come to fruition? I think it's both. And I think that that would already have come to fruition? I think it's both. And I think that that's what makes them so fascinating as kind of cultural...
就是让他们作为文化……如此迷人的原因。
So what about, let's say, India? The Beatles? I mean, that's a huge thing because Western society, particularly in Britain, had always had a kind of Orientalist fascination and there'd always been this fascination with Oriental spirituality and so on. But do you think that would have come about in the 60s in the same way? I mean, the Maharishi is already there in London giving a talk, I think,
那么，比如说印度呢？披头士？我的意思是，那是一件大事，因为西方社会，特别是英国，一直有一种东方主义的迷恋，一直对东方灵性等等有这种迷恋。但你认为这会在60年代以同样的方式出现吗？我的意思是，马哈里希（Maharishi）已经在伦敦发表演讲了，我想，
when the Beatles first discover him at one of the hotels, in one of the Mayfair or Bart Lane hotels. So all the Beatles are brought up as Christian. Lennon and McCartney meet famously, as we've said, at a church fete. George Harrison has... He's very interested in spirituality, Catholic spirituality.
当披头士第一次在酒店，在梅菲尔（Mayfair）或巴特巷（Park Lane）的酒店之一发现他时。所以所有的披头士成员都是作为基督徒长大的。正如我们所说，列侬和麦卡特尼在教堂游园会上相遇。乔治·哈里森有……他对灵性，天主教灵性非常感兴趣。
And in money. He's certainly interested in money as well. Yes. Complaining about the tax man. And they come to see Christianity as boring because Christianity in 1960s Britain is boring. It's stale, it's dull, it's associated with hierarchy, it's losing its self-confidence.
还有金钱。他当然也对金钱感兴趣。是的。抱怨税务官。他们开始觉得基督教很无聊，因为20世纪60年代的英国基督教确实很无聊。它陈腐、乏味，与等级制度挂钩，正在失去自信。
This is the period where people in the church are saying they don't believe in God. Honest to God and all that stuff. And so that's why I think it's perfectly reasonable for John lennon to say that they're bigger than jesus they certainly are in um in england but i think that um they they have absorbed a lot of christian assumptions and and so they're you know the key message of you know peace and love which ring even ringo says all the time peace and love, which even Ringo says all the time, peace and love.
这是教会里的人说他们不相信上帝的时期。诸如此类的“诚实面对上帝”之类的东西。所以我认为约翰·列侬说他们比耶稣更受欢迎是完全合理的，在英国他们确实如此，但我认为他们吸收了很多基督教的假设，所以你知道，他们那句核心信息——“和平与爱”，连林戈也一直在说，和平与爱，连林戈也一直在说，和平与爱。
These are basically Christian ideals. And all you need is love. I mean, that's an enduring Christian message. And the fact that they sing all you need is love as their contribution to a global festival of culture, all these satellites around the world
这些基本上都是基督教的理想。你所需要的只是爱。我的意思是，这是一个持久的基督教信息。事实上，他们演唱《All You Need Is Love》作为对全球文化节的贡献，所有这些环绕地球的卫星
joining people up from around countries around the entire globe. The Beatles singing All You Need Is Love, it's Britain's contribution to what they see as a kind of universal message. It draws on pretty fundamental Christian ideas. The problem is because Christianity's image
将全球各国的民众连接在一起。披头士乐队演唱《All You Need Is Love》，这是英国对他们所认为的一种普世信息的贡献。它借鉴了非常基础的基督教思想。问题在于，因为基督教的形象
is so boring and dull and staid, the Beatles are not interested in that. The Maharishi kind of provides that. And the Maharishi, you know, he's packaging his message for Western tastes rather in the way that, you know, Indian food is packaged for British taste. He's the chicken tikka masala of gurus.
太无聊、太乏味、太刻板了，披头士对此不感兴趣。玛哈礼希（Maharishi）提供了一种替代方案。你知道，玛哈礼希在为西方口味包装他的信息，就像印度菜为英国口味包装一样。他是大师中的“咖喱鸡”。
Yeah, he's the chicken tikka masala of mid-60s spirituality. And George Harrison is kind of, I guess, the archetype of this because he remains a very Catholic kind of Hindu. And the way in which My Sweet Lord, the smash hit that he releases after the Beatles have broken up, the chorus goes from Alleluia, Alleluia, to Hare Krishna, Hare Krishna.
是的，他是60年代中期灵性界的“咖喱鸡”。乔治·哈里森大概是这种人的原型，因为他始终是一个非常天主教式的印度教徒。他解散后发行的热门单曲《My Sweet Lord》，副歌从“哈利路亚”变成了“哈瑞奎师那”。
But it sounds exactly the same. And I think that, again, they're both representative and influential on what seems to me a pretty fundamental trend, certainly here in Britain, that the guiding assumption now of our elites is that all religions are basically the same. Surely they all teach you peace and love
但听起来完全一样。我认为，这再次代表并影响了一种在我看来非常根本的趋势，至少在英国是这样，即我们精英阶层现在的指导假设是所有宗教基本上都是一样的。难道它们不都教导和平与爱
and basic fundamentals. And I think the role the beatles play in that is is fairly hefty was that turning into a bit of a paul mccartney-ish impersonation there when you said i didn't notice it but if it was it may be i'm marina hyde and i'm'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
和基本原则吗？我认为披头士在其中扮演的角色相当重要。刚才你说那句话时，是不是变成了一点保罗·麦卡特尼式的模仿？我没注意到，但如果是的话，也许吧。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
So let's talk about the Beatles and their wealth and celebrity. So I'm trying to think if there have been people... Imagine no possessions. Well, yes. John Lennon
那么，让我们谈谈披头士乐队以及他们的财富和名声。我在想是否有人……想象没有财产。嗯，是的。约翰·列侬
and his massive house in, where is it, Weybridge? Yes. St George's Hill where the Diggers had started to set up their commune in the 17th century. And it's now a gated community.
和他那座巨大的房子，在韦布里奇？是的。圣乔治山，17世纪掘地派（Diggers）开始建立公社的地方。现在它成了一个封闭式社区。
Yeah. And I've tried to go and visit it so many times, and every time I get turned away by Russian bodyguards. Both Wynne Stanley and John Lennon would, you know, turn in their graves. It's strange that you have nothing else to do, Tom, than hang around outside the gates of other people's houses. Well, I do, but, you know but periodically I try and get to see it.
是的。我试过很多次去参观，但每次都被俄罗斯保镖赶走。温斯坦利和约翰·列侬肯定会从坟墓里跳出来。汤姆，你除了在别人家门口晃荡，难道没别的事可做了吗？嗯，我有，但你知道，我还是会定期尝试去看看。
But I'm trying to think if there are people before the Beatles in British, certainly in British cultural history, who had either the international fame or the amount of money overnight that they did. And I think that's another, to me, that's another obvious area where they're pioneers, where it's hard to, so this is why... I mean, what they do is they do what entrepreneurs and manufacturers would have done 100 years earlier, which is they buy country houses. It's interesting that they haven't freed themselves from the shackles of their Britishness.
但我是在想，在英国文化史上，在披头士之前，是否有人拥有过他们那样一夜之间获得的国际名声或巨额财富。我认为这是另一个明显的领域，他们是先驱，很难……我的意思是，他们所做的是100年前的企业家和制造商会做的事，那就是购买乡间别墅。有趣的是，他们并没有从英国身份的枷锁中解放出来。
So their instinct is immediately... I mean, Lennon and I think George, they buy these stockbroker belt houses and then they go into the bigger sort of National Trust style. But Paul McCartney doesn't. No, that's what makes him interesting. And what's interesting is Paul McCartney, who's always seen as the more conventional of Lennon and McCartney,
所以他们的本能是立刻……我的意思是，列侬和乔治，他们买了这些股票经纪人居住区的房子，然后他们进入了更大规模的国民托管组织（National Trust）风格的住宅。但保罗·麦卡特尼没有。不，这就是他有趣的地方。有趣的是，保罗·麦卡特尼一直被视为列侬和麦卡特尼中比较传统的一位，
is actually much more interested in the avant-garde and is at the heart of Swinging London when it's at its most swinging. Well, that's because of his association. I mean, that's an interesting thing about class because McCartney has an in with the Asher family which is a very well connected patrician culturally connected family through his relationship with Jane Asher
实际上对前卫艺术更感兴趣，并且处于“摇摆伦敦”最鼎盛时期的核心。嗯，那是因为他的交际圈。我的意思是，关于阶级这是一个有趣的事情，因为麦卡特尼通过与简·阿舍的关系，进入了阿舍家族，这是一个文化联系紧密的贵族家庭。
he basically moves in with her doesn't he and that's how he discovers Stock Housen and all this sort of business yeah but I think what's interesting about them is that they are they're a new kind of elite that Britain had not previously produced.
他基本上搬去和她住了，对吧？这就是他发现斯托克豪森和所有这些东西的方式。是的，但我认为关于他们有趣的是，他们是英国以前从未产生过的一种新型精英。
So Dickens wasn't unmoored from his society in the way that they are to become later on. Do you not think? Yeah, I do. And I think that that's what makes particularly John and Yoko interesting. Because obviously... The Harry and Meghan of the 1960s. The Harry and Meghan of the 60s.
所以狄更斯并没有像他们后来那样与社会脱节。你不觉得吗？是的，我同意。我认为这正是约翰和洋子特别有趣的地方。因为显然……他们是60年代的哈里和梅根。60年代的哈里和梅根。
It's evident that John Lennon living in his stockbroke about house is desperately unhappy because he's lonely and bored and he doesn't know what to do with it. And he is kind of deracinated, I guess. I mean, he's lost his roots. And so he's looking for something else. And his relationship with Yoko, I mean, symbolised
显而易见，住在股票经纪人区房子里的约翰·列侬非常不快乐，因为他孤独、无聊，不知道该拿这些财富怎么办。他有点“去根”了，我想。我的意思是，他失去了根基。所以他在寻找别的东西。他和洋子的关系，我的意思是，象征着
by his replacing Winston as his middle name with Ono. I mean, it's quite a, it's kind of wonderfully culturally symbolic. But he blazes a path that many people have followed now. And you could say that the whole, he blazes a path that is currently convulsing the nation.
他把中间名温斯顿换成了小野（Ono）。我的意思是，这非常具有文化象征意义。但他开辟了一条许多人现在追随的道路。你可以说，整个……他开辟了一条目前正在让国家陷入动荡的道路。
I think. Yes. No, I think that's true. I mean, Lennon's an interesting one, isn't convulsing the nation, I think. Yes. No, I think that's true. I mean, Lennon's an interesting one, isn't he? Because he basically, I mean, ironically, having said the Beatles were bigger than Jesus, he then decides to dress like Jesus. He does, yes. And to look like Jesus.
我想是的。不，我认为这是真的。我的意思是，列侬是一个有趣的人，不是吗？因为他基本上，讽刺的是，在说了披头士比耶稣更受欢迎之后，他决定打扮得像耶稣。他确实是，是的。而且看起来像耶稣。
And his sort of role, I mean, he definitely sees himself, I mean, he would love your thesis, because your thesis is how he thinks of himself, right? As a moral prophet rather than as a musician. But do you think that sort of moral prophecy still has force all these years on? I mean, do you think young people give a damn about John Lennon now?
他的角色，我的意思是，他绝对把自己看作……我的意思是，他会喜欢你的论点，因为你的论点就是他如何看待自己，对吧？作为一个道德先知，而不是一个音乐家。但你认为那种道德预言在这么多年后还有力量吗？我的意思是，你认为现在的年轻人还在乎约翰·列侬吗？
I don't think they give a damn about John Lennon, but I think the way in which he set himself up as a kind of holy fool, the way in which he deliberately sought to trash things that people held sacred. So I watched, Dorian Linsky was here at the festival yesterday talking about protest songs, and he made the kind of wonderful point that John Lennon's protest songs are basically lists
我不认为他们还在乎约翰·列侬，但我认为他把自己塑造成一种“神圣的傻瓜”的方式，他故意试图摧毁人们认为神圣的事物的方式。所以我看了，多里安·林斯基昨天在音乐节上谈论抗议歌曲，他提出了一个非常精彩的观点，即约翰·列侬的抗议歌曲基本上就是
of things that he doesn't agree with, that he doesn't like. And there's the song God on on his first solo album where he goes through all the things that he had previously valued and now he he doesn't so he famously says i don't believe in beatles but he also says i don't believe in god i don't believe in jesus i don't believe in buddha i don't believe in yoga basically he is the way in which you get cultural capital by trashing things that people hold sacred seems to me quite significant. Yeah.
他不同意、不喜欢的事物的清单。在他第一张个人专辑里有一首《God》，他列举了所有他曾经珍视但现在不再相信的东西。所以他著名地说“我不相信披头士”，但他也说“我不相信上帝，我不相信耶稣，我不相信佛陀，我不相信瑜伽”。基本上，他通过摧毁人们认为神圣的事物来获取文化资本的方式，在我看来非常重要。是的。
Because that's what we're living through at the moment. And he really does seem to me a trailblazer there. There's a story, isn't there? Elton John went to visit him in New York and saw John and Anna getting very cross because one of the golden doorknobs had come off in the apartment or something well and elton says elton says to him imagine no possessions john and john says it's only an effing song um quite quite but because i think that that the hypocrisy is also a crucial part of it.
因为这就是我们目前正在经历的。他确实在我看来是一个先驱。有一个故事，对吧？埃尔顿·约翰去纽约拜访他，看到约翰和洋子因为公寓里的一个金色门把手掉了而变得非常生气。埃尔顿对他说：“想象没有财产，约翰。”约翰说：“那只是一首歌而已。”嗯，确实，确实。但我认为这种虚伪也是其中的关键部分。
And that also is a massive part of the tension that the cultural revolution that we're going through is having to wrestle with. Because you've got people who are casting down the statues but then filming it on their iPhones, which are made from materials that have been sourced by basically slaves. So the hypocrisy there is also, you know, John Lennon and Yoko Ono,
这也是我们正在经历的文化革命必须面对的巨大张力的一部分。因为你有一些人推倒雕像，然后用iPhone拍摄，而这些手机的材料基本上是由奴隶开采的。所以那里的虚伪也是，你知道，约翰·列侬和洋子，
they're in their hotel room and they have to stop their protest because the chamber mate has to come in and make their bed. Yeah, I always like that detail. That's their bed in, isn't it, in Amsterdam? That's their bed in, in Amsterdam. So I think he's...
他们在酒店房间里，他们不得不停止抗议，因为服务员得进来铺床。是的，我一直很喜欢这个细节。那是他们在阿姆斯特丹的“床上和平运动”，对吧？那是他们在阿姆斯特丹的“床上和平运动”。所以我认为他……
I think John Lennon in particular will be a subject of great fascination to future historians. I mean, do you not think so? Well, I've written about John Lennon. I mean, I've never had worse feedback than when I've written about John Lennon because, as you know,
我认为约翰·列侬尤其会成为未来历史学家非常着迷的对象。我的意思是，你不这么认为吗？嗯，我写过关于约翰·列侬的文章。我的意思是，我写关于约翰·列侬的文章时，收到的反馈是最差的，因为如你所知，
I don't really hold a candle for John Lennon. Is that morally or musically? He's everything I dislike in a person. I know that's quite strong. So let's tease this out. What do you not like about him? I don't like beards. Long hair.
我真的不太喜欢约翰·列侬。这是道德上还是音乐上的？他是我在一个人身上最讨厌的所有特质的集合。我知道这话说得很重。那么让我们深入探讨一下。你讨厌他什么？我不喜欢胡子。长头发。
I don't like... I mean Long hair. I don't like... I mean, to me, the hypocrisy is incredibly glaring. The empty, self-regarding kind of moral gestures, which, you know, you love with all your holy men and all that sort of thing. I don't like that. You see, I don't think they were empty. I think he was looking around. I mean, the bed looking around for ways to fill that kind of sense of emptiness.
我不喜欢……我的意思是，长头发。我不喜欢……我的意思是，对我来说，这种虚伪极其明显。那种空洞、自以为是的道德姿态，你知道，你喜欢你所有的圣人以及所有那一套。我不喜欢那个。你看，我不认为它们是空洞的。我认为他在四处寻找。我的意思是，床上……在寻找填补那种空虚感的方法。
I think the bedding is laughable. He tried lots of things and lots of them didn't work, but he drew attention to his campaign for peace. And you may say it didn't actually work. But the idea of give peace a chance, the idea that militarism per se is wrong, the suspicion of war, of
我认为“床上和平运动”很可笑。他尝试了很多事情，很多都没有奏效，但他引起了人们对他和平运动的关注。你可能会说它实际上并没有奏效。但“给和平一个机会”的想法，军国主义本身是错误的观念，对战争、对
armed forces, I think that's now a huge part of cultural life, certainly in Britain, certainly in America, in a way that it simply wasn't in the 60s. But it's not like nobody had thought of that before, Tom. Think about what a huge thing pacifism was in the 1930s when people were signing peace pledges
武装部队的怀疑，我认为这现在是文化生活的重要组成部分，肯定是在英国，肯定是在美国，这在60年代根本不是这样。但并不是说以前没有人想到过这一点，汤姆。想想30年代当人们签署和平誓言时，和平主义是多么重要，
or the moral fervour of the Victorian era. I mean, the idea that he's the first person to popularise them. I'm not in any way saying that, but I think he popularised it in a distinctive way that becomes associated with youth culture and each generation inherits it and broadens it out. You know, he used to work at Speak Airport. He used to spit in people's sandwiches.
或者维多利亚时代的道德热情。我的意思是，他并不是第一个推广这些理念的人。我绝不是这么说，但我认为他以一种独特的方式推广了它，使它与青年文化联系在一起，每一代人都继承并扩展了它。你知道，他以前在斯皮克机场工作。他以前往别人的三明治里吐口水。
But it's that element of savagery. That's just bad behaviour. Of course it's bad behaviour. If I spit in your sandwich at lunch, will you say, oh, that's an interesting moral position or something? Of course you won't. No, but you didn't write Imagine. Well, that's one thing in my favour. Come on.
但那是野蛮的成分。那只是糟糕的行为。当然是糟糕的行为。如果我在午餐时往你的三明治里吐口水，你会说“哦，那是一个有趣的道德立场”吗？你当然不会。不，但你没写过《Imagine》。嗯，那是我的一大优点。得了吧。
Right, have we got anything more to say on the subject of Beatles as epical, historical figures before we open it up to questions? I think we should open it up for questions. You'll have to shout incredibly loud. Does anyone have questions?'ll have to shout incredibly loud.
好了，在我们开放提问之前，关于披头士作为史诗般的历史人物，我们还有什么要说的吗？我认为我们应该开放提问。你们得大声喊出来。有人有疑问吗？你们得大声喊出来。
Does anyone have questions? Hold on, we'll just get you a microphone and you can twist and shout. Dylan was writing songs like With God on Our Side, Times Are Changing, sort of pre-Beatles. To what extent do you think he influenced them and maybe deserves some of the credit you're stealing for the Beatles?
有人有疑问吗？等等，我们给你拿个麦克风，你可以尽情扭动和尖叫。迪伦在披头士之前就写过像《With God on Our Side》、《Times Are Changing》这样的歌。你认为他在多大程度上影响了他们，也许应该获得一些你归功于披头士的赞誉？
Go on, Tommy. You're probably a Bob Dylan fan, aren't you? I'm not a Bob Dylan fan. No, I'm not either. But that doesn't mean I can't recognise it. I mean, I think his lyrics are terrible. I can't believe he got the Nobel Prize. I mean, you just read them out. They're absolutely gibberish. Beatles lyrics are much
继续，汤米。你大概是个鲍勃·迪伦的粉丝，对吧？我不是鲍勃·迪伦的粉丝。不，我也不是。但这并不意味着我不能认可他。我的意思是，我认为他的歌词很糟糕。我不敢相信他获得了诺贝尔奖。我的意思是，你读出来看看。它们完全是胡言乱语。披头士的歌词要
better. She loves you, yeah, yeah, yeah. There's a kind of honesty there I mean obviously Dylan is a huge cultural figure as well and we're not saying that the Beatles are absolutely you know equivalent to the 60s the Stones and Bob Dylan
好得多。《She Loves You, yeah, yeah, yeah》。那里面有一种诚实。我的意思是，显然迪伦也是一个巨大的文化人物，我们并不是说披头士绝对等同于60年代的滚石乐队和鲍勃·迪伦，
and you know these are huge figures as well but I don't think Bob Dylan had a fraction of the Beatles' global popularity. And I think it's that global popularity that makes the Beatles significant as figures of historical study. So this isn't a discussion about musical influence. And it may well be that Dylan's musical influence
你知道，这些也是伟大的人物，但我认为鲍勃·迪伦的全球知名度不及披头士的零头。我认为正是这种全球知名度使披头士成为历史研究的重要人物。所以这不是关于音乐影响力的讨论。迪伦的音乐影响力可能
has been just as great or possibly greater than that of the Beatles. But I think as figures who served as lightning rods for a convulsive period of social and cultural change, the Beatles are unrivaled. I would completely agree with that, Tom. I think the difference is that Bob Dylan appeals to a specific constituency, I would say. He's obviously got a market that, and large, I would guess, is
一直和披头士一样大，甚至可能更大。但我认为，作为动荡的社会和文化变革时期的避雷针，披头士是无可匹敌的。我完全同意这一点，汤姆。我认为区别在于鲍勃·迪伦吸引的是特定的群体，我想说。他显然有一个市场，而且很大，我猜是
pretty well educated, affluent, probably sort of liberal politically and so on and so forth. Whereas I think the Beatles appeal to people who are not political, to people who are maybe not particularly well educated. It's obviously
受过良好教育、富裕、政治上可能比较自由等等。而我认为披头士吸引的是那些不关心政治的人，那些可能受教育程度不是特别高的人。这显然
so much greater and as you say, the Beatles are an extraordinary international reach. I mean it's hard to imagine that example that Tom gave at the beginning of the North Korean figure skaters they're unlikely to do it. I'd love to see it though like a Rolling Stone, that would be amazing wouldn't it? Yeah I would
要大得多，正如你所说，披头士有着非凡的国际影响力。我的意思是，很难想象汤姆开头举的那个朝鲜花样滑冰选手的例子，他们不太可能那样做。但我很想看到，像《Like a Rolling Stone》那样，那会很棒，不是吗？是的，我会
I think also though the difference between Dylan and the Beatles and indeed the Beatles and the Rolling Stones or the Who or any is that they start the 60s and indeed the Beatles and the Rolling Stones, or the Who, or any, is that they start the 60s and they end with the 60s. And there's a kind of perfection to their story. So I remember
我也认为，迪伦和披头士之间的区别，实际上是披头士和滚石乐队、谁人乐队（The Who）或任何乐队的区别在于，他们开启了60年代，也终结了60年代。他们的故事有一种完美感。所以我记得
we did an episode on, one of the very earliest podcasts we did was on the year 1981. And so we talked about Diana, and how the story of Princess Diana, simply as a story, is kind of unbelievable. It's so perfect, the kind of the tragedy of it, the arc of it. And I think the Beatles are very similar. I think the story is one that bears endless repetition. It's kind of like the modern matter of Britain.
我们做过一期关于1981年的节目，那是我们最早的播客之一。我们谈到了戴安娜，谈到了戴安娜王妃的故事，作为一个故事，简直令人难以置信。它太完美了，那种悲剧性，那种弧线。我认为披头士非常相似。我认为这个故事值得不断重复。它就像现代的“不列颠史诗”。
And the way in which they are kind of playing emblematic roles at all the key moments in the 60s. They're in Hamburg. They're in America after the assassination of Kennedy. They're there during the religious and cultural convulsions of America in the mid-60s. They're hippies. They're there when it all starts to go wrong and to sour,
他们以某种方式在60年代的所有关键时刻扮演了标志性的角色。他们在汉堡。他们在肯尼迪遇刺后的美国。他们在60年代中期美国宗教和文化动荡期间在那里。他们是嬉皮士。他们在一切开始出错和变质时在那里，
and then they break up at the end of the 60s, I think makes their story just kind of perfect. It's kind of mythic, isn't it? I mean, they're mythic heroes, and I think that, exactly, they have that trajectory that nobody else has. Any other questions? We've got a couple over... Yes, hi.
然后在60年代末解散，我认为这让他们的故事变得非常完美。这简直是神话般的，不是吗？我的意思是，他们是神话英雄，我认为，没错，他们拥有其他人没有的那种轨迹。还有其他问题吗？我们那边有几个……是的，你好。
I'm a big fan of the podcast, and I'd just like to congratulate Tom for getting through a whole episode without mentioning genitalia. Well, two virgins. The two virgins. Let's give that a shout out. The famous John and Yoko
我是这个播客的忠实粉丝，我想祝贺汤姆在没有提到生殖器的情况下完成了一整期节目。嗯，还有《Two Virgins》。那张著名的约翰和洋子
full frontal nude album cover. He's absolutely incorrigible. Why do you encourage him? I think, wasn't it that that prompted the Queen to say to some EMI bigwig, the Beatles have gone very strange. Yes, you did.
全裸专辑封面。他真是无可救药。你为什么要鼓励他？我想，是不是那件事促使女王对某位EMI高管说，披头士变得非常奇怪。是的，你做到了。
Yeah. Well, didn't they go and they presented it to the head of EMI or whatever, Sir Joseph Lockwood? Yes. And he said Paul McCartney would look a lot better naked than you. Anyway. There was a question, sorry. Sorry, yes.
是的。嗯，他们不是去把它呈献给EMI的老板约瑟夫·洛克伍德爵士了吗？是的。他说：“保罗·麦卡特尼裸体看起来会比你好看得多。”总之。刚才有个问题，抱歉。抱歉，是的。
You set us off. Yeah, well, I just sort of wondered, I mean, from the cultural relevance of them in the last 50 years is obviously because, I mean, I have a generation probably like you where post-Beatles but grew up listening to their music and, you know, most famously, obviously, Oasis was very influenced by them as well. But I sort of wonder whether or not,
你让我们跑题了。是的，我只是有点好奇，我的意思是，从他们过去50年的文化相关性来看，显然是因为，我的意思是，我这一代人可能和你一样，是在披头士之后，但从小听着他们的音乐长大，而且，你知道，最著名的是，绿洲乐队（Oasis）显然也深受他们影响。但我有点怀疑，
back to kind of where you started this talk, does the passing of The Last Beatle whenever Paul McCartney or Ringo Starr die mean that they kind of just go into being historical figures and whether or not they do actually have a legacy that kind of goes beyond that? I think they will. For what it's worth,
回到你开始这次谈话的地方，最后一位披头士成员的离世——无论保罗·麦卡特尼或林戈·斯塔尔何时去世——是否意味着他们就仅仅变成了历史人物，以及他们是否真的拥有超越这一点的遗产？我认为他们会有的。不管怎么说，
and I'm not in any way an expert on music at all but i think their music will last um and i think that even if it i i i think that the i think particularly mccartney's tunes are so strong live and let die frog chorus inevitable Frog chorus. Inevitable cry goes up. Yesterday. I think that they will endure. But in a way, that's not what I'm saying. I think that as figures who are representative of a convulsive period, not just in British, but in global history, they will be subjects of enduring historical fascination, I suspect. Dominic disagrees. I sort of agree with the implication of the question, which is that
我绝不是音乐专家，但我认为他们的音乐会流传下去，而且我认为，即使……我认为特别是麦卡特尼的曲子非常强劲，《Live and Let Die》、《Frog Chorus》……不可避免的《Frog Chorus》。不可避免的呼声响起。《Yesterday》。我认为他们会永存。但在某种程度上，我不是这个意思。我认为作为代表了一个动荡时期的形象，不仅是在英国，而且是在全球历史上，他们将成为持久的历史迷恋对象，我怀疑。多米尼克不同意。我有点同意这个问题的暗示，即
youngsters in 2050 will be listening to very different kind of music that we can't now imagine, made with different... It's highly unlikely that it will involve guitars, I would have thought. And the Beatles will seem like a historical curiosity. They will be as remote to our successes as Victorian figures are to us. Now, that's not to say that a great Victorian like Dickens or Darwin, they haven't left a legacy, but will most people know who George Harrison was in 2070?
2050年的年轻人会听着我们现在无法想象的、用不同方式制作的非常不同的音乐……我认为这不太可能涉及吉他。披头士看起来就像一个历史奇观。他们对我们的后继者来说，就像维多利亚时代的人物对我们一样遥远。现在，这并不是说像狄更斯或达尔文这样的维多利亚时代伟人没有留下遗产，但大多数人在2070年还会知道乔治·哈里森是谁吗？
I think it's utterly implausible. So, you know, people who are fascinated by history will know who they were. But beyond that... That's the most I'm saying. But on the music, I do think that they seem to have a kind of, certainly so far, a degree of immortality that no other band.
我认为这完全不可信。所以，你知道，对历史着迷的人会知道他们是谁。但除此之外……这就是我所说的全部。但在音乐方面，我确实认为他们似乎拥有一种，至少到目前为止，其他乐队所没有的某种不朽。
But do you not think that's almost as... Not even the Stones, not even the Beach Boys, not even the Who. Do you not think that's almost as slightly... I mean, one thing that really strikes me thinking about the Beatles in my own childhood was I first encountered them at school. Now, I went to a very, very old-fashioned prep school
但你不觉得那几乎……甚至不是滚石，甚至不是海滩男孩，甚至不是谁人乐队。你不觉得那几乎有点……我的意思是，在我的童年时期，想到披头士，有一件事真的让我印象深刻，那就是我第一次在学校接触到他们。现在，我上的是一所非常、非常老派的预备学校，
in the West Midlands where we sang Yellow Submarine in about 1980, 1981 or something. So very quickly, I mean remarkably quickly, they had gone from being the stuff of chart toppers to the stuff of kind of six or seven-year-olds singing as a sort of their little class hymn almost. And I think that, I can see their music surviving like that. Like nursery rhymes.
在西米德兰兹郡，我们在1980年、1981年左右唱过《Yellow Submarine》。所以非常快，我的意思是极其迅速，他们从排行榜冠军变成了六七岁孩子唱的某种班级赞美诗。我认为，我能看到他们的音乐像那样流传下来。像童谣一样。
Like nursery rhymes, exactly. So I think that that will be see their music surviving like that. Like nursery rhymes. Like nursery rhymes. Like nursery rhymes, exactly. So I think that that will be, yeah. Okay, we agree. We do. Well, kind of, Dominic, kind of. Which one of us, I... Oh, I think I was right.
像童谣一样，没错。所以我认为那会……看到他们的音乐像那样流传下来。像童谣一样。像童谣一样，没错。所以我认为那会，是的。好吧，我们达成一致了。我们达成了。嗯，某种程度上，多米尼克，某种程度上。我们俩谁……哦，我想我是对的。
I think I was right. I was just wondering. No, you're John Lennon. No, I think you are. Why? In what way? Because I'm more enthusiastic. That's what people always say.
我想我是对的。我只是在想。不，你是约翰·列侬。不，我想你是。为什么？哪方面？因为我更热情。人们总是这么说。
People always say you're a cynical grump. And people say that I'm wide-eyed. They do. Tiggerish. Tom was absolutely outraged because the Times ran a review of the podcast and they said he was Tigger and I was Owl. And then I had my phone. I text.
人们总是说你是个愤世嫉俗的怪人。人们说我眼界开阔。他们确实这么说。像跳跳虎一样。汤姆当时非常愤怒，因为《泰晤士报》刊登了对播客的评论，说他是跳跳虎，我是猫头鹰。然后我拿到了手机。我发了短信。
I can't believe they called you Owl. I can't believe it. Yeah. So Lennon and McCartney. I've got a question up here at the top of the hill well not the top but half way up you mentioned before that we are probably living through a cultural revolution similar to the one that our forefathers lived in the 1520s
我不敢相信他们叫你猫头鹰。我不敢相信。是的。所以列侬和麦卡特尼。我在山顶有个问题，嗯，不是山顶，而是半山腰。你之前提到我们可能正在经历一场类似于我们祖先在1520年代经历的文化革命，
and that Martin Luther published his pamphlets but also the songs at the time were very influential, so what the songs at the time were very influential. So what happened there? Did the singing in church move from Latin to German? Why did you say that? Because I think that profound cultural, social, dare I say religious upheavals are not just a matter of, you know,
马丁·路德发表了他的小册子，但当时的歌曲也非常有影响力，所以当时的歌曲非常有影响力。那么那里发生了什么？教堂里的歌唱从拉丁语变成了德语吗？你为什么这么说？因为我认为深刻的文化、社会，甚至宗教动荡不仅仅是……
in the context of the 16th century theology, or in the context of, you know, the second half of the 20th century, of a Grampskean ideology, or Foucault, or thinkers, all of whom obviously are very, very important. But it's the way in which it gets propagated out, so that people kind of just imbibe it. And I think that the way in which the Beatles' music and the music, the messages about the importance of love, about the importance of giving peace a chance, succeeds generation to generation, I think is kind of very important.
在16世纪神学的背景下，或者在20世纪下半叶，葛兰西意识形态、福柯或思想家的背景下，所有这些显然都非常、非常重要。但这是它传播出去的方式，让人们只是吸收它。我认为披头士的音乐和音乐、关于爱的重要性、关于给和平一个机会的重要性的信息，一代又一代地成功传承，我认为是非常重要的。
And it gels a lot with the kind of ideological impetus of what's going on. And that's a crucial part of why it's so potent. So the parallel is that in the Reformation, or in kind of latter iterations of Protestant reawakening, the reawakeningsings the reawokenings um music is a very very important part of it because it conveys messages that will reach people that more overtly programmatic ideological intellectual messaging simply won't yeah music and art i suppose and i see it's raining and if only only the Beatles had written a song about the rain. Are you going to start singing?
它与正在发生的事情的意识形态推动力非常契合。这就是它如此强大的关键部分。所以相似之处在于，在宗教改革中，或者在后来的新教觉醒迭代中，音乐是非常、非常重要的一部分，因为它传达的信息能够触及那些更公开的纲领性、意识形态、知识分子信息无法触及的人。是的，音乐和艺术，我想。而且我看到下雨了，要是披头士写过一首关于雨的歌就好了。你要开始唱歌了吗？
Please don't. People run and hide their heads, I think, don't they? They might as well be dead, which is a cheery thought. So have we got one more question? Clearly glutton for punishment. Yes, I do. It's somewhat tangential to the gentleman on the hill. If we assume that we are going through a cultural revolution
请不要。人们会跑去躲起来，我想，对吧？他们可能和死了一样，这是一个令人愉快的想法。所以我们还有一个问题吗？显然是自讨苦吃。是的，我有。这与山上的那位先生的问题有点偏离。如果我们假设我们现在正在经历一场类似于1520年代的文化革命，
similar to the 1520s now, and given the context of where Britain was and where Britain is today with the existential question of whether Britain actually does exist, to what extent would you argue that Britain, the British Empire and the British Cultural Revolution was in fact British or English? Okay, that's an absolutely colossal question. My answer would be that it was British, that there was such a thing as Britishness
考虑到英国过去的位置以及今天英国关于英国是否真的存在的存在主义问题，你会认为英国、大英帝国和英国文化革命实际上是英国的还是英格兰的？好吧，这是一个极其宏大的问题。我的回答是，它是英国的，确实存在“英国性”这种东西，
and indeed for a lot of people still is, that there was an identity that went beyond Englishness and that obviously that has now corroded a little bit, that the decline, because Britain is no longer able to really define itself against an other, which was always Catholic France for a long time. Once that threat receded, then Britishness itself
而且对很多人来说仍然存在，有一种超越英格兰性的身份认同，显然现在已经腐蚀了一点，这种衰落，因为英国不再能够真正定义自己以对抗一个“他者”，这在很长一段时间里一直是天主教法国。一旦那个威胁消退，那么英国性本身
seemed less necessary, I suppose. And you're right that the Empire became very closely associated with Britishness. And so I think if, let's imagine a scenario in which Great Britain, as it were, did break up, then when people
似乎就不那么必要了，我想。你是对的，帝国与英国性紧密相连。所以我认为，如果，让我们想象一个大不列颠解体的场景，那么当人们
look back at where that started, where that process began, actually that period, 50s, 60s, is where they would start, I think, with the decline of the British Empire, growth of Scottish and Welsh nationalism
回顾这一切开始的地方，那个过程开始的地方，实际上那个时期，50年代、60年代，就是他们会开始的地方，我想，随着大英帝国的衰落，苏格兰和威尔士民族主义的增长
and so on. And, yeah, the sort of questioning of icons, of sacred symbols, if you like, the sort of questioning of icons, of sacred symbols, if you like, the sort of revising of history, all that sort of stuff. I mean, that does feel like, I think Tom is right, that the 60s does feel like the epicentre of that. I mean, I think on the issue of Britishness and specifically the Beatles,
等等。而且，是的，那种对偶像、神圣符号的质疑，如果你愿意的话，那种对历史的修正，所有这些东西。我的意思是，这确实感觉，我想汤姆是对的，60年代确实感觉像是这一切的震中。我的意思是，我认为关于英国性，特别是披头士的问题，
I think the fact they come from Liverpool is quite significant because famously Liverpool is open to American influence because records are coming in from America, imported by sailors and so on. And so that's how the Beatles are particularly alert to this cultural influence. But it's also massively influenced by Irish immigration. And so there's always an awareness of Ireland
我认为他们来自利物浦这一事实非常重要，因为众所周知，利物浦对美国的影响是开放的，因为唱片是从美国进来的，由水手等进口。所以这就是披头士特别警觉这种文化影响的原因。但它也深受爱尔兰移民的影响。所以总是有一种对爱尔兰的意识，
as a kind of hinterland as well as England and Paul McCartney releases Give Ireland Back to the Irish Give Ireland Back to the Irish as a very sophisticated contribution to the
作为一种腹地，也作为英格兰，保罗·麦卡特尼发行了《Give Ireland Back to the Irish》，作为对这个
thorny issue. But of course he also famously sings Mull of Kintyre and one of the I mean it's quite is it a deliberate contrast to John Lennon and Yoko in their mansion singing about no possessions
棘手问题的非常复杂的贡献。但当然，他也著名地演唱了《Mull of Kintyre》，我的意思是，这是否是对约翰·列侬和洋子在豪宅里唱着“没有财产”的刻意对比？
that after the Beatles break up he basically retires to a farm on the Mull of Kintyre and leads quite a normal life. But that's what I would do if the rest of history breaks up. You would go to New York. I'm not John Lennon. I'm not John Lennon.
披头士解散后，他基本上退休到金泰尔角的一个农场，过着相当正常的生活。但如果历史的其余部分解体，我也会那样做。你会去纽约。我不是约翰·列侬。我不是约翰·列侬。
You would be the one in the bloody penthouse. I would be by the side of a lock in a farmhouse. Simple life. Writing columns for the Daily Mail. Yeah, but you've retired to the country
你会是那个住在该死的顶层公寓里的人。我会待在农舍的湖边。简单的生活。为《每日邮报》写专栏。是的，但你退休到了乡下，
whereas I'm in the heart of swinging London. Okay. Jane Asher sitting there., whereas I'm in the heart of Swinging London. Okay. Jane Asher sitting there at the front. Jane Asher sitting in the corner, yeah. So casting Catherine as Yoko. Yeah. I'm sure she'd be thrilled about that.
而我身处摇摆伦敦的中心。好吧。简·阿舍坐在那里。简·阿舍坐在角落里，是的。所以让凯瑟琳扮演洋子。是的。我相信她会为此感到兴奋。
She'd be delighted. Thank God she's not here. Yeah. Yeah. Any more questions before we all get drowned by the rain? Isn't one area of huge influence of the Beatles the fact that millions of people around the world learnt to speak English listening to Beatle lyrics,
她会很高兴的。谢天谢地她不在这里。是的。是的。在我们都被雨淋透之前还有更多问题吗？披头士巨大的影响力之一难道不是全世界数百万人通过听披头士的歌词、
listening to Beatle songs? I think that probably is an interesting point. I think no non-English speaking band could have had the success that they had. I think English was already something of a lingua franca. And they often, you know, they were very, I mean, obviously it's interesting
听披头士的歌学会了说英语吗？我认为这可能是一个有趣的观点。我认为没有非英语国家的乐队能取得他们那样的成功。我认为英语本身已经是某种通用语了。而且他们经常，你知道，他们非常，我的意思是，显然这很有趣，
they'd gone to Hamburg in Germany, a place where people already spoke pretty good English, but obviously the British army was stationed. So there would be people with, who are even more exposed to English. But they record versions of their,
他们去了德国汉堡，一个人们已经说得很好英语的地方，但显然英国军队驻扎在那里。所以会有更多接触英语的人。但他们录制了他们的
some of their early songs in German. Yes, they do. They wouldn't have broken through, I think, if they'd sung in German. No. Germany, do you? But they're versions of their early songs in German. Yes, they do. They wouldn't have broken through, I think, if they'd sung in German. No. Do you? But they're very European figures. Oh, yeah.
一些早期歌曲的德语版本。是的，他们录了。我认为如果他们用德语演唱，他们就不会取得突破。不。德国，是吗？但他们录制了早期歌曲的德语版本。是的，他们录了。我认为如果他们用德语演唱，他们就不会取得突破。不。你觉得呢？但他们是非常欧洲的人物。哦，是的。
They're very influenced by... In France, they're called the Yeah Yeahs, aren't they? Yeah. But the German artistic elite, the Xs, as they're called, the existentialists, in turn are influenced by France. So they're very influenced by that. Well, the haircuts and all that.
他们深受……在法国，他们被称为“Yeah Yeahs”，不是吗？是的。但德国的艺术精英，所谓的“X”，存在主义者，反过来又受到法国的影响。所以他们深受其影响。嗯，发型和所有那些东西。
Their beetle cut comes from Paris, a trip to Paris. So they are not solely British figures. They're very European, I think. But I agree about, yes, about the English language aspect of it. There's a brilliant song that was released by an Italian artist, I think in the late 60s, who didn't speak English, who sang
他们的披头士发型来自巴黎，一次巴黎之行。所以他们不仅仅是英国人物。我认为他们非常欧洲。但我同意关于英语语言方面的看法。有一首意大利艺术家发行的精彩歌曲，我想是在60年代末，他不会说英语，他用
it in what he thought sounded like English. Which, you know, if you're an English speaker and you want to know what English sounds like to someone who doesn't speak English, it's the perfect way to do it. Because it kind of vaguely does sound like English, but it's complete gibberish. That's Danish. There's a huge sign here saying, Time's Up, in red. way to do it because it kind of vaguely does sound like English but it's complete gibberish that's Danish yeah right
他认为听起来像英语的方式演唱。这（如果你是一个英语母语者，想知道英语在不会说英语的人听起来是什么样子的，这是完美的方式）。因为它听起来确实有点像英语，但完全是胡言乱语。那是丹麦语。这里有一个巨大的牌子写着“时间到了”，红色的。方式，因为它听起来确实有点像英语，但完全是胡言乱语。那是丹麦语。是的，没错。
there's a huge sign here saying time's up time's up in red so I think time is up yeah and in the end yeah
这里有一个巨大的牌子写着“时间到了”，红色的，所以我想时间到了。是的，最后，是的。
the love you take is equal to the love you make so on that on that bombshell on that bombshell thanks very much for listening thank you thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你付出的爱等于你得到的爱。所以，带着这个重磅炸弹，感谢大家的收听，谢谢。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。获取额外剧集、提前访问、无广告收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。